[Music]
we should devote something to the
audience watching at home and here in
the studio we have the same birthday not
just the same
uh date uh three years same way we were
exactly the same age we were born the
exact same
time date everything and for all those
people that have always suspected now
you go i knew they were twins yeah we
just you know because it's it's
the rumors have been out there but now
now we can now we know
so it was a big birthday this year we'll
both come clean it was the big 5-0 for
both of us we're collectively a hundred
we're collectively a hundred years old
and you
uh what did you do for yours i had like
a big fortune i got a bracket i didn't
do anything my wife
god bless her i i said a little just to
have a little party some friends over
she does but as i'm making a toast or
something all of a sudden a woman
appears scantily clad and begins dancing
and i'm thinking
it's a scriptagram no this is four
dancers there were four
dance burlesque dancers that do seven
numbers it was really hot and very sexy
and and then and at the end of the last
number this girl
takes her skirt off and i brought a
picture i don't know if you have it but
this this is what this is there
[Music]
that wasn't you know wow yeah that's
incredible what a crazy coincidence yeah
to get that girl that happened to have
that i mean it was a birthmark uh i was
i was afraid you know to look at 50 and
then i was like what a what a blowout i
know that's fantastic it was it was
great fun i got to tell you my assistant
was backstage he just told me this is a
true story speaking of that picture
a friend of his so into your show
several years ago that he had your
cartoon and your cartoon on his ass
tattooed for life he's got he's got you
and you forever can i just say something
for fans that want to do that those
tattoos age very badly
it's kind of a cute idea for a while and
then later on late in life
that's just not going to look i'm going
to look like a drunk sad leprechaun on
your ass yeah
so that was it but i you know i give it
up for your wife for for giving you such
a great blog she's amazing because that
is a big birthday and what was great is
she's having a great time and and i'm
having a great time but there's 15
couples at our house
not sure what to do
you know there's like every guy's like
can i can i look is this all right am i
allowed to can i divorce my wife and go
with janet now
that would be a no yeah
that's definitely gonna have to do that
there were like four numbers dude like
was it it was only four if it was long
it was great and they're all very
talented and there's at least one guy
reaching in going is this a key party
where do i put where do i put these you
know and the and the the wives are all
looking at each other like i'm if i want
if i enjoyed this do you judge me do you
talk about me on the school playground
it was great it was fantastic
what an amazing birthday yeah i'll i'm
gonna be 50 again next year yeah so i'm
going to
do that you know what my wife took me on
my 15th the sizzler
50 was written on my tray in fries
exactly